who I have this saying that we are not
from Norway we're from Bergen
absolutely historic folks he is
done job coming
there's one thing to lose because you're
a weaker performer but if you lose
because you choose a bad tactics then
you just beat yourself up because tactic
is so easy to do something with it's
just like a matter of choice the most
important factor is iteration and enough
sleep
[Music]
being these outliers Outsiders nobody's
really paying attention to what you're
doing this is over 10 years in the
making
your 2022 Vin fast Iron Man world
champion is Gustav you Eden
hey everybody Welcome to the podcast
well today we're in for a treat we've
got a couple Vikings in the house the
Norseman taking over the world of
triathlon with ferocity their names are
Gustav Eden and Christian blumenfelt and
between these childhood friends and
constant training companions hailing
from Norway there is no stone left
unturned and no Championship left
unconquered in an unprecedented period
of just nine months Christian was
crowned Olympic champion in Tokyo he
recorded the fastest Ironman performance
ever in his debut at the distance in
Cozumel he became the first person to go
under seven hours at the 140.6 distance
in the sub 7 project clocking and
astonishing assisted yes but still
astonishing six hours and 44 minutes and
he also walked away Victorious at the
2021 IRONMAN World Championships in St
George Utah on the other hand hot off an
absolutely spectacular debut victory at
the IRONMAN World Championships in Kona
a race in which Christian placed third
Gustav Eden who happens to be the 2021
70.3 world champion has now definitively
emerged from Christian's formidable
shadow
smashing the overall Kona course record
with a blistering 7 hours 40 minutes and
24 seconds also rewriting the Marathon
course record with a two hour 36 minute
and 15 second 26.2 along the way
personally I was absolutely glued to the
Iron Man World Championship live stream
all day on October 8th it was a barn
burner of a race in which Christian and
Gustav raced in tandem until the very
end and it was an absolute thrill to
host both of them in studio literally
just two days after the Epic race the
details of which we cover extensively in
this conversation
we also discussed the nature of their
unique training protocols what a day in
their lives looks like the extreme
science and data mining that underscores
their training and racing protocols as
well as their advice for amateur
athletes and more in other words
how do they do it why are they so much
better than everyone else and what the
heck is going on in Norway anyway
final note if you dig this five I also
recorded a separate podcast with their
coach olav Alexander boo who is a bit of
a Mad genius and that's an amazing
conversation that we will be releasing
on a future undetermined as of now date
so there is that to look forward to
anyway waste further precious seconds we
will not the Norwegian train is in the
house so uh let's uh tuck into that
Arrow position
Hammer some watts and enjoy
welcome guys I'm so excited to talk to
you how you guys feeling uh right now
I'm extremely tired my quotes are not
good yeah but I'm yeah extremely happy
satisfied combination of
hangover and just lack of sleep and
yeah I asked you guys if you were able
to sneak in a little partying after the
race but no right you had to get on a
plane and get to La yeah so we went to
the bank yet afterwards but that's just
more like an award ceremony so no party
and uh yeah I went straight to bed and
came here came here your bikes didn't
make it but I can't see what like how
people can even stay awake like I mean I
was like it was getting up like 3 30 in
the morning and then racing whole day
and then uh one evening is coming I'm
just so so tired yeah maybe they're
saving themselves for the after party
and that's why not winning maybe that
after part is probably going on right
now I would imagine well I'm delighted
that uh you've carved out time in your
busy schedule uh just sit down with me
it's just a treat and an honor to talk
to you both on the wake of such an
extraordinary race but before we even
kind of get into any of that I need to
remind you that the most important thing
is that merely a year ago at the Malibu
Triathlon my relay took both of you guys
out and really that is what is important
today
you remember that that's true did you
win over us I don't think we want maybe
did you guys win I know we'd be
Christian's team who was on your relay
uh it was me uh
and uh one of the actors from uh some
Dustin I can't remember the name maybe
you guys did you guys win the relay I
think we won right or at least we came
on a Podium I think we got the second or
third I can't remember I had I think
Alexis and Mary Kane on my team okay
anyway just outside just outside yeah
priorities right the Malibu Triathlon
celebrity real life that was a fun one
um listen you guys what you both have
accomplished together separately is is
absolutely mind-blowing
um obviously the big story uh is Kona
the other day a race in which all the
barriers were broken all the records
were smashed and mostly by rookies like
of all the men in the top four
they were all rookies right Iron Man uh
Hawaii rookies at least and uh Gustav
you broke the previous Court course
record set by yawn for Dino back in 2019
absolutely destroyed it Christian you
were third but you're coming off an
Olympic Victory the fastest ever Iron
Man you know ever recorded the sub seven
project I mean between the two of you
guys there is uh no record that has been
left untouched and uh it's it's really
an extraordinary feat so here we are
days after Kona and I guess you know I
asked you how you're feeling but have
you had a moment to kind of reflect back
on the race with some perspective on
what this means and kind of what it's
setting you up to do next I just felt
like I'm in work working from selfie to
selfie and media request to Media
request so I haven't really had the time
to sit down with uh Oola my coach and
Christian to do a bit more analyzing and
yeah really
see how we we did so yeah I don't think
I realized
What I've Done Yet yeah I think we have
two different uh
feelings about race because obviously
both of us want to win and
so I like when I flew in here yesterday
like when I was listening to music the
only thing I was thinking about like
why didn't I win like and then what
could have done differently and so I've
had a little bit of time to reflect uh
but it's just like in the back of the
mine right so obviously uh unfinished
business for you Christian
um and it's interesting because you know
you guys grew up together you've known
each other forever you do all your
training together there is this
camaraderie this friendship but also a
rivalry and you know all eyes were on
the both of you running together you
know through the latter part of the
marathon who was going to break away and
when was that going to happen and most
of the spotlight has been on you
Christian because of your past
performances Gustav you haven't yet had
you hadn't yet had that opportunity to
really kind of flex and and shine you
missed that opportunity in St George by
being sick so this was really your
moment did you have the confidence going
in that you could accomplish this are
you surprised or you know how are you
feeling about kind of emerging from you
know I don't want to say shadow in a
pejorative way but you've always been
sort of a little bit you know behind
Christian in terms of attention and
expectations even though you won the
70.3 world championship and all the rest
of the your accomplishments yeah so I
don't think I linked my confidence to
past performance that much and
especially not to Media attention so
back in 2019 I looked at myself as a
favorite to win the
to win the 713 World Championship even
though basically no one thought I could
do it so yeah for sure I I thought I
could win this race uh as I said me and
Christian training together and we know
where the level is at and I felt really
strong and especially the Run lately so
I knew I had a really good chance of
beating Christian in a race and I knew
if I was beating Christian the the
reigning world champion then
I think it would be that everyone else
as well yeah and and this rivalry that
you have are you still buddies like you
guys cool with each other you got to
spend all this time together yeah it's
uh it's like so I would say a quite cool
dynamic because uh in training we tried
to build each other build each other up
as much as possible and really get the
best out of every training session
but it's on race day it's uh
it's the same up to a certain point
where you're trying to uh you're working
together yeah you're working together
you also you want to beat him but you
also want him to perform so it's uh yeah
I felt we had like a moment on the way
back from Harvey when mongers have had
penalty yeah and we had Sam laidlow up
front yeah even though we didn't believe
he would be able to run and then we were
like maybe on both understanding now
okay now it's actually just a race
between you and me yeah but then still
we can't let Sam get away and we can't
get the guys behind just to catch up so
we still have to work together yeah so
it's a really um interesting Dynamic I
have to say yeah there was a lot of
teamwork on the bike and on the run I
mean I noticed coming out of every aid
station you would swap who would lead
like there was a lot of like cooperation
there until it's sort of coming out of
the energy lab and then it's anybody's
game that wasn't really collaboration
tell me what was going on yeah
I I went to the lead and had a lead
um yeah for for most of the run but I
didn't want to
there's one thing to lose because you're
like a weaker performer but if you lose
because you choose a bad tactics and
that you could done differently and done
one then you just beat yourself up
because tactic is so easy to do
something with it's just like a matter
of choice and if I had run up to energy
lab in the front in the headwind the
whole way and Christian would take me
like the last few uh case I would be so
so so mad sure
you get in front yeah I try to make him
go to the front as well just upside and
downside by training so much together
like because I knew that he was coming
in in Great Run shape and if I wanted to
have a chance to beat him I couldn't
share the work with him I had to really
yeah play my card right and so every
time yeah we both try to play our cards
and we're just that they didn't match up
so yeah and it's interesting because you
know each other's cards so there's no
secrets right yeah but I was a bit
uncertain because uh yeah Sam laidlow
way up front he still had like four
minutes or 3 40 uh after I don't know
20K or something
and uh
uh I knew that I had to run quite fast
to catch him because it was no sign of
him blowing up and I had my brother on
course and he said Sam is actually
looking good right and yeah no sign of
him blowing so uh yeah I wanted to catch
him obviously but also didn't want
Christian to just sit behind and wait
for for a Sprint right for you so I made
him go to the front but every time he
went to the front he was running yeah
not slow in like the general slowness
but quite a bit slower than what I was
running when I was to the front so we're
actually losing a bit of time when he
went to the front and I thought that
this guy is playing it so cool now he is
uh yeah doing like this insane mental
game trying to get me to work the whole
way but I realized that soon we were
fighting for a second place and none of
us Wanted only right second place so
then I have to have to make my move and
yeah go after it yeah I mean it was
interesting uh seeing laidlow up front
for so long and the expectation being of
course that he would blow up he's a
rookie so young it's just a matter of
time you guys are gonna you know eat
this guy alive at some point and yet he
continued to maintain that Gap uh you
know kilometer after kilometer and even
into the run right it's so at some point
you realize like we got to make a move
probably earlier than we would have
ordinarily because this guy might make
it to the Finish Line like it becomes uh
you know a matter how much real estate
you have left so I know in a you know
there was an interview with you Gustav
there was some sort of smack talking
between the two of you guys Christians
here were like well I've been beating
Gustav in training for the last two
weeks handily this is going to be no
problem and you were saying yeah but you
know he doesn't know I'm holding back
wait till the last five miles but you
made your move it I think with like
eight miles to go yeah so my plan was
always to really kick it off the energy
lab
uh we developed our new shoe together
with on and it's been a really really
cool project and that's you you got the
plug-in the sponsored this is yeah I'm
working off to the point now so but
there's just some media training in you
the shoe is is made for their like the
faster bits like downhill and uh
Tailwind it's just perfect for those
conditions so out of energy lab was
struggling a bit was going uphill and so
he did struggle yeah but a Christian
also had a gap on me there so I thought
he was just playing with me well I did
also but I I did lose you guys haven't
talked about this yet not not too much
we're going for media media the media so
this is the first time we have to lay it
all down so you get the you get the
fresh uh appreciate that yeah keep going
um
but yeah he had a gap on me there and I
knew that he knew that he got a gap on
me and normally when you have a gap that
is where you try to accelerate a bit to
just break the rubber but uh yeah he
didn't do it so then I knew how he was
like
kind of on the limit so out of energy
lab I just accelerated and right and
went for it yeah and when you made that
acceleration you knew you had to Gap him
like with Force right rather than just
sort of slowly pull him along like you
had to just break the chain
for Christian or for Sam for for
Christian yeah to get that Gap yeah and
then to eat up time so that you were
sure you were going to pass Sam in time
before the Finish Line yeah at that time
I was more worried about Sam actually
because uh he was still two minutes up
the way and no sign of slowing down but
I I ran a lot like a period area around
a three minute case in uh in a marathon
it was it was downhill but uh so what
was that I was just looking at PACE like
five thirties or something quick I have
no idea I know you guys do kilometers
yeah
um insane like when I
my my kind of overall takeaway just from
watching the race is that it's just at a
whole new level like I'm used to seeing
um you know people blow up on the run
and even the best like walking at times
or throwing up and having GI issues all
that stuff that you know we've all seen
over the years and this just looked like
a Sprint from start to finish obviously
you had incredible conditions there
wasn't any wind
um so it's not a surprise what's that it
didn't look like I mean these bike
splits are unreal yeah but it was still
was win but the wind was it was quite
favorable it wasn't like insane
conditions but it was good and
especially on the run I felt like it was
a lot of wind especially going out yeah
did you get some overcast late in the
day or no
um no no it wasn't a start right in the
beginning of the yeah yeah but also the
start was like earlier this year didn't
you you guys started in the dark
basically which is unusual yeah 625 yeah
so maybe that I don't know yeah first
time
Rook is an island but nobody's blowing
up nobody's walking nobody's vomiting
everybody is so dialed like even through
transitions everything like the
execution was Flawless so the
competition level is just you know
beyond anything that we've ever seen I
mean it's crazy like even
um
I mean keenly had like an unbelievable
race was that his fastest time yeah and
he was way back there you know I was
like he didn't even fifth or something
like that I think how many guys broke
the pre-course record I think it was
only laidlow who broke the bike course
yeah well no I think like a bunch of you
well Cam's record was like 409 I think
right okay
oh you did yeah okay I thought a whole
bunch of guys yeah but the overall
record plenty of people did oh yeah yeah
yeah for sure but 10 guys on the eight
hours that like it's just like four five
years ago that was like the gross record
as well right so the whole field has
been
just improving and getting faster and I
guess getting more knowledge about how
to really raise a full distance arm and
not just finish it right because often
there has been uh yeah the last survivor
was gonna win and now you really have to
be able to be tactical and really push
that last bit and raise it yeah no
mistakes you can't make any any mistakes
and expect to win
one of the things about Kona this race
in particular and the big island is sort
of the Mystique around it the
spirituality of the island the Mana you
know uh not ruffling the feathers of
Madame Pele and I know Christian you're
like I don't have time for that like
that's a bunch of nonsense uh but having
not achieved your goal this year are you
rethinking that are you gonna are you
gonna get down on your knees for Madame
Pele a little bit you know like Mark
Allen talks a lot about this and it took
him seven years and it wasn't until he
kind of like had a reverence or or like
a humility for the forces of that very
special place that he was able to
conquer it and win maybe I should have
put a lava rock in this bag yeah so he
left never to yeah like that yeah the
worst Omen for people that don't know
like never remove a lava rock from you
know I think uh like they still had a
decent performance myself so it's not
like I blew up and walked in NG lab so
uh I don't think it was the mystery of
the island that did that I didn't win so
yeah of course um
like watching those um
the videos from his finish shoot and
like seeing all the people there and
it's really uh brace I do want to cross
the finish line first and uh I do have
to come back and
experience that feeling yes it was
amazing yeah it was uh it was amazing
and uh I actually spoke to mark
a bit about it so
uh it's if as a winner you have to have
a speech not the at the bank yet and ask
them what what should I say and he said
that um I should give more credit to the
island and less credit to my lucky hat
so I have yeah so what did you say did
you take that out no no he's speaking
some wisdom there I should ponder that
do some journaling around that idea
um you you said after the race like I
don't know if I'm coming back like one
and done is that how you're feeling
still I wouldn't say one and done but I
would come back first thing
um for now it's all about Paris Olympics
from 2024 and uh
yeah it's uh
it's hard to keep your priorities
straight when you have so many
opportunities and you have so many
things to do so I think for now it's
better to just say no and uh try to
focus only on Paris right and Christian
reflecting on on the race and your
performance are you thinking about how
you can improve what went wrong where
you can make changes like where where is
your head at you're not used to you know
coming in third so what is this what's
going on inside that brain well now it's
more like to understand why I was
struggling so much to keep up with him
on the run like if it was because of the
surges on the bike or if I was just like
good enough in your own training before
uh but it's difficult to have like a
pure answer to it um
[Music]
so
yeah back in the lab all right John
you're just questioning yourself like
all the time and uh you just feel like
okay I really have to come back yeah
well you seem like somebody who is
motivated by these sort of circumstances
I think I'm getting more motivated by
this yeah like finishing third and I'm
by winning races because then it's just
back in the mind and just yeah it's like
painful the whole for weeks afterwards
and luckily now we have another race in
Saint George in June we start two and a
half weeks and uh that's more like okay
I can get my revenge there and use death
to kind of forget this verse a little
bit right I mean typically after a race
like Kona most athletes would take a
break in two weeks you have 70.3s no
break for you guys and that's an
interesting amount of time like you
can't really do any build up you've got
to recover from Kona all you can do is
really uh sort of rest and sharpen the
edge of your sword a little bit right
like but it's not just that we have St
George we have the following week we go
back again to Olympic distance for the
Bermuda race and then
three weeks later we had a grand final
so we've been through all the different
distances it's like this is like
mid-season for you yes so uh I think we
used three four days more for Recovery
yeah and then uh maybe some intensity
for the weekend and then trying to dial
in some speed again for a short distance
right all right so you guys are known as
the Norwegian Train everybody is
fascinated by what's happening in Bergen
I'm going to talk to olav after I talk
to you guys and we can dive into the
science but I think people are
fascinated by and interested in like
what it is that you guys are doing
that's different like why are you so
good why are you so fast so can we talk
a little bit about your approach to
training and what has distinguished you
guys from what everyone else is doing I
think it's uh people talk like what's in
the water in Bergen or something but I
think it's it is slightly random that we
have that many good athletes from Bergen
but it's definitely a culture thing
so uh me and Christian we have been yeah
basically in local training for
yeah 15 years yeah like you guys were
like 13 years old so even before that we
did a lot of training but uh we have
been I see myself as uh as a
professional since I was basically 14
years old I was training better than
than some pros do today so I think it's
been a lot of volume high quality
training for many many many years that
has made us into the athletes we are
today and it's not some yeah
I don't know and higher power and I
guess we're also been living in this
bubble like within the group and not
just looking at what everyone else is
doing but we're like if we want to catch
up we have to be more extreme we have to
train more we have to
uh take it like one step further in
every uh part of the sport and I think
also the fact that it would have been
like in that bubble has really helped us
to
yeah just accelerate right kind of being
these outliers Outsiders nobody's really
paying attention to what you're doing
and you could kind of go deep
um when the stakes were low and there
were no expectations and you know find a
certain kind of GrooVe that ultimately
is paying dividends I mean this is like
over 10 years in the making and there's
no history in the sports because we had
no history who had to make the pathway
yourself so we haven't just been
following someone uh and uh if you're
known for being the ones of chain the
best the ones who've trained the most
extreme it's kind of like a positive
feedback loop so since everyone's saying
is yeah you're training the best you're
smarter so scientific you kind of uh
grow into that even more and that makes
you think okay we have to do everything
more have to do everything more
scientific so it's for sure it's good to
be known to be good because then you
thank you uh you're good yourself so I
think it's something about that as well
well I see it as a Confluence of all of
these factors that you couldn't have
predicted like you have you you're you
come from a cycling background
originally right and Christian you come
from swimming swimming so believe it or
not yeah no I can believe it
um
at a time when uh Norway hadn't put
anybody on a triathlon Olympic team for
I don't know how long ever maybe never
never before uh but suddenly you have uh
an interest in Norway for truly
developing a professional approach to
the sport
um with what was his name arid to viten
yeah yeah I'm not I'm never going to
pronounce that right and who came into
the picture around 2011 and then with
olav entering around
2015-16
observing what was going on at the uh
Rio Olympics and then bringing a whole
level of new professionalism
um and science into the approach so it's
like these individuals who kind of come
together with athletes like yourself and
Casper of course who are highly
motivated and willing to go all in like
without any one of those elements none
of this happens so it's kind of a really
special thing I think of it as sort of
like
um
like like Bergen and Triathlon is not
dissimilar culturally from like what was
happening with Grunge music in Seattle
in the 90s like it's a it's like a
special place where there's an energy uh
and a focus that you know ultimately
over time you know ripples out and
creates something really cool and unique
and I think also the fact that when we
saw this so young we had this uh 10
years Vision within the team so when we
were 16 17 we had it wasn't just that we
should be winning the junior World
Championship the next year or getting
into the uh yeah next World Cup we did
think like 10 years ahead and we had
that support and believe in
understanding that it's like a long
journey right we're having ahead of us
uh when we started back in 2010 2011 and
think we've got support from Olympic TV
and team even in 2014 and not just for
Paris now I mean for um
Rio or not just for Tokyo but also for
Paris back in right 10 years ahead and
that long-term Mission I think uh has
been good to have like dinos it's so
important that long-term view like we're
not going to be you know world champions
overnight we're going to take we're
going to look at this in 10-year blocks
and we're thinking way way down the line
like for anybody who's trying to achieve
any kind of goal like having that kind
of lens and you know building the
foundation and the consistency over a
huge period of time I mean that's truly
how you achieve outdate outdate
outrageous audacious results
yeah and
um yeah we've done a lot of things right
over the years but we have also learned
a lot and I think the way we approached
it in a start was a bit too extreme for
for many of the athletes so Christian
said it's uh the egg yeah philosophy egg
philosophy so you take the whole basket
of eggs and just throw it at the wall
and then see who who doesn't crack you
weeded out a lot of people early so how
many of you are how many are there of
you now on the team
from the start we are
four
yeah so we haven't compared to like
bigger nation who haven't burned through
too many definitely but we had uh quite
a few dropouts away in the start because
uh yeah the volume was a bit High and a
lot of injuries and yeah but that's also
because we didn't have any qualification
standards it was more like we'll open up
the door so everyone who wants to come
in like if I'm just thinking about
Triathlon you could come in and be a
part of the source camp that we had so I
think it's also so uh back then uh I I
want to be my brother and one of the the
main guys in Trials on Norway he said
those Eden Brothers they will never
learn how to swim they will never become
anything he have like said that he
regret those words and it's really a
cool dude but it's a bit funny looking
back now yeah the ultimate Revenge yeah
you've had on that they didn't actually
say it to me though so that's good right
sorry to interrupt the flow we'll be
right back with more awesome but I want
to snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition the thing is
most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to
incorporate more whole plants more
fruits vegetables seeds beans and
legumes into their daily routine sadly
however without the kitchen tools and
support very few end up sticking with it
so because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly and
because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced we
decided to tackle and solve this very
common problem the solution we've
devised I'm proud to say is the plant
power meal planner are affordable
all-in-one digital platform that sets
you up for nutrition Excellence by
providing access to thousands of Highly
customizable super delicious and easy to
prepare plant-based recipes everything
integrates with automatic grocery
delivery and you get access to our
amazing team of nutrition coaches seven
days a week and many other features to
learn more and to sign up visit
meals.richroll.com and right now for a
limited time we're offering ten dollars
off an annual membership when you use
the promo code rrhealth at checkout this
is life-changing stuff people for just a
dollar seventy a week literally the
price of a cup of coffee again that's
mealss.richroll.com promo code rrhealth
for ten dollars off an annual membership
all right
let's get back to the show let's talk
about the particulars of of the training
and the data mining that you guys are
doing I mean I think you know most
people who are who are in the endurance
world or who have participated in
Triathlon or Iron Man kind of understand
lactate testing fundamentally or Zone
training and periodization but you guys
have taken kind of those traditional
approaches and just elevated it to a
whole new place like I think you're
you're you're doing like lactate Pricks
like multiple times throughout every
single session doing multiple sessions a
day seven days a week like what what
exactly like dispel some of the Mystique
here like what walk me through like what
you're understanding and I'll get deeper
into it with Olaf but from your
perspective as athletes like what are
you doing when
um you're doing all this testing and how
is that impacting your approach to
training recovery and racing
yeah so uh it's not that we do lactate
on every single session but there's some
periods really have more focus on it and
uh we do lactate both to like calibrate
your own feeling of intensity control
so
um it is uh I think it's a lot of
mystery how we do the lactate testing
and no one is really understanding it
completely and that even includes me so
we do uh yeah I understand the numbers I
understand how I'm feeling but sometimes
uh olav is saying something that doesn't
really make sense to me but then we do
one more test and it's like yeah it was
correct so the lactate testing is so
Advanced that yeah and basically what
it's doing it's telling you where your
certain thresholds are like how much
you're dipping into your glycogen stores
like how you know are you training your
aerobic engine are you tipping into your
anaerobic like what are you learning
about that that then impacts like the
kind of sessions that you're doing well
it's quite complex so uh the whole idea
is to just maximize so to have your
engine and so you can really maximize
your energy distance you're Racing for
example when we have preparing for a
short distance race then we want to have
like a different like that response uh
for the energy yeah or what we're
getting energy from and uh uh so
sometimes you do want to have like a
quicker like like that production for
example for a shorter distance of racing
and when you go into a longer distance
and you want to have the opposite so
it's
really depends on where your metabolic
profile is
right and you guys are very different
athletes right and I'm sure your
training is very personalized to your
specific yeah so we uh in general we
Trend opposite directions so if we just
train exactly the same I will Trend uh
more and more explosive but Christian
will try and slightly different
direction
and uh so we have to do some uh some
adjustment in the training plan so we do
some uh yeah small metabolic tests to
see where we're at because uh yeah we
have like this
um a period of uh really specialization
into the race so the last bit of uh
preparation going into Kona Olaf said uh
yeah yoga style we need to pit a bit
more threshold training into this
program now because you're
you're trend is uh not where we want it
to be so we have to do slightly
different so it's not that we're
training
like a different program but it's more
instead of the last 10 minutes of uh
threshold session I might go longer like
twice the distance but Christian might
go harder to like balance out their
different uh right you have you you're
more of like a top end guy Christian you
have this huge anaerobic capacity but
that means that you have to learn how to
back off right because you can dip into
that and go too deep too too soon no I
think more opposite like uh I got that
all wrong
even though I look very muscular and
like strong
I do miss that top end power so I really
need to do those surges in training so
well he naturally had that top end speed
and he can do it final case super fast
converting but that's going to be more
costly for him right for me he'll need
more recovery really sprinting that's
fine okay so often how we like do our
session different currently into a big
race is that I can do more high
intensity but I might do a long
threshold session instead right right
right and that's also why I can race
back to back to back short distance
races because
the stimulus I'm getting from the race
is almost just a positive stimulus for
next weekend well you will then be
producing more and more left it so
explosive Beast towards the end right so
you have a higher you have a crazy VO2
max Gustav right yeah
above nine theater or Peaks right but
right now I'm I'm certain I'm pretty low
so the
yeah it cost a lot to have a high view
to Max and to do an Ironman you want to
be as efficient as possible so we now
basically at our lowest view to Max I
think in a few years because of the
general training we've been doing so now
it's a challenge to try to you got to
get it back up to get it back up and get
it to the standard of the Olympic
distance racing right and you Christian
like you you you you're sure like
Michael Phelps like you don't produce
lactate right it's so annoying sometimes
I I like have to slow down slow down
slow down in altitude training
especially we're training uh Sierra
Nevada in Spain 2 300 meters above sea
level I don't know what that is in feet
it's like 8005 isn't it yeah
and uh uh yeah I feel like I'm jogging a
threshold and I still have too high
lactate so just have to slow down and
then I say fish down oh yeah you need
you have to increase you're running too
slow right and uh even though it's the
it's the right stimulus I need to run
slower because that is the best way for
me to perform you feel so [ __ ] when
you're when you're training at the speed
slower than my arm and pace
so
um yeah it's uh it can be a bit annoying
sometimes seeing his right because
conversely Christian like altitude
doesn't really affect you right but you
then you also don't get that hemoglobin
used from that I do get it stimulus but
I think it's more down to I have such
big lungs so I try to work I can I'm
just I still have enough oxygen for the
the workload or like to say to keep the
Pace High yeah so it's yeah especially
when we do bike intervals then we start
that
yeah 3000 feet and work our way up and I
feel so good in the start right like now
it's a lot of oxygen and I'm ready to
push low life date
and that may come like halfway off the
mountain and I see Christian like just
increasing the power and I'm just
struggling more and more so it can be a
bit annoying to train it sometimes with
his lactate response but uh yeah I know
it's the best for me so it helps but
yeah there I'm opposite because if we
are riding down from Seattle Nevada
things tend to be like 25 degrees it's a
significant warmer than it's up in
Nevada so I'm more feeling the heat is
slowing me down and then the higher up
the climb like up to uh maybe 1700 2000
meter that's where like the fresh air is
coming so when he is starting to feel a
lack of oxygen then I'm more feeling the
bonus of having fresh cold air so I can
just accelerate what's interesting about
that is it's got a It's gotta keep the
training because you guys do all your
training together fresh like you're very
different right so it's not like if you
were equally matched in your strengths
and weaknesses you guys might burn out
like having to train with each other
every single day but understanding that
you operate differently you can still
you know have that camaraderie because
it's not like uh I don't know like
you're not you don't you're not like
racing each other every single day no no
no no no so uh
I we like to like win every single
session but to win a session it's not
that you go the fastest the last 400
meters except if we have like a race
prep session and the point is to go as
fast as they can it lasts for 100 meters
it's more that you want to hit the
optimal numbers all the time you want to
to have the best execute on the
attention yeah yeah so I think that's
where we're excelling the most as well
because uh
we have a deeper understanding of what
we're doing and why we're doing the
session and if you know why you're doing
a session you understand the
more the changes you can do yourself so
if someone just tells you around 10
times 1K and they don't understand why
you're doing it you wouldn't just go out
and do 10 times 1K but if you have an
understanding of what pace you should be
running at then what the optimal
execution is then you can for example
run yeah Progressive or the last bit
even faster or yeah you can change up
the session according to what your daily
need is so I think that's where we are
really really good yeah and what is the
partnership with Olaf like like does he
say here's what we're doing and then you
do it or is it more a dialogue where
you're like okay here's how I'm feeling
today like is there a discussion about
it is there ever pushback when he says I
want you to do this and you're like no I
don't think I should be doing that today
or sometimes just whatever he says you
do yeah so uh he can say we we should do
this and then me and Christian will come
with a suggestion now we want this and
then he says why we shouldn't do it and
explains why we are wrong or or but then
you have to take the consequences yes of
that yeah so it's all about consequences
so we can say yeah we need to swim a bit
harder because in the swim we'll be
lacking a bit um me and Christian both
thinks that uh we need to change the
same program a bit and do a bit shorter
and more intensity swim sessions in the
pool and it's like yeah you can do that
but here's the consequences and we we do
a lot of discussion and ulav is uh great
teacher so we we learn why we are wrong
right we also plan or he plans like
probably six months yeah in advance
but then also like we change maybe and
then you have like the three weeks plan
then you can also change like the last
three four days we always like have like
a bigger picture a bit with no change
very quickly the sessions so if we
within the next week see that uh we are
what we want to be in terms of Vietnam X
right and we are not just keeping up the
program and trying to improve it Max
just because that's a plan and then we
can change the focus and work on our
limitation for the next phrase right but
since they plan so much in advance we
can come to a training session and he
have no idea what we're doing like here
here planned everything he knows why
we're doing it he knows uh like the
details when he's planning it but when
we come to the training session it's
like I can't remember why I wrote this
but must be a reason behind it we we
don't have to tell him the program when
he's at the pool there okay today we
have the 400s with 90 seconds rest and
then it takes like maybe one minute he
have to like scan his whole brain and
then he comes up he remembers why we're
doing it and then we can uh do the
session got it or he can change it yeah
no I'm not agree with myself two weeks
ago let's change it yeah two weeks ago
me was stupid oh no let's change to 400
meters instead yeah
um Christian if you if you pull up the
sleeve on your left arm you can see the
uh continuous glucose monitor that you
have there do you wear one as well I'm
interested you guys so are you both with
super sapiens on that yeah
um what have you learned from using that
in terms of you know how you're managing
glucose and how that impacts
um your daily nutrition and also race
nutrition
yeah so uh for me the biggest learning
was that sometimes in especially
attitude training I could get really
really tired and borderline sick and it
usually happened yeah twice every
attitude camp and then I noticed uh
throughout the night before I got tired
I had basically low sugar levels through
the whole night and just trying to be
more aware of the continuous eating and
even if the rest I tried to stay on top
of the nutrition and eat more so I it
impact the type of foods that you eat
not really and I was I was surprised
actually because you think that drinking
Coke or yeah sugary product that you
would spike but for me I Spike the same
if I eat bread or like slow releasing
carbohydrates and everything so it's uh
yeah for me it's only the mornings I
have like ink it's saying spike in the
morning no matter what I eat but I
haven't I haven't changed my breakfast
or anything I just see see what the
number give me and much the same like
and I think the most important is like
you're learning to really feel quickly
after sessions we're always like on top
of the nutrition so because if not it's
easy to go like 46 minutes after a tough
pronunciation before getting your some
something to eat but when you're aware
of your glucose level it's easy to be
kind of
planning and then
uh having a routine so you're always
having like calories on board right so
monitoring that is that
spill over into how you're feeling
throughout a race a fueling throughout
the race is pretty simple it's uh get as
much much in as you can tolerate
so uh
um we're working with uh Morton right a
Swedish company and uh that has allowed
us to basically go way way way higher in
the carbs than what is normally
considered okay for the stomach
so uh I think using super sapiens could
be helpful but it's basically just do as
much as you can tolerate for us and then
even there we're doing some samplings
for we are so because of the special
types of carbohydrates that's in the
Morton uh olavan the Morgan team can
base in our breath analyze how many
grams we're able to take up when you are
riding based on your breath yeah and
then by looking at the the master or the
oxygen intake we're using and the power
they can then calculate how sustainable
this is so so you know for Ironman it's
easy to do 350 Watts for a given period
of time but when you don't have to do it
for
uh or 300 watts for like four hours and
then run after it then
at one point you will most likely just
bunk but but based on this like you can
calculate and see like how far you can
get and how much power you can produce
without yeah ending up in the basement
right yeah there is something specific
about what Morton is doing that is
really helpful in terms of of staving
off the GI distress that you see
particularly in humid places like Kona
yeah so they have this technology that
doesn't uh the carbs don't get absorbed
as early as other products so it that it
it is basically encapsulated in hydrogel
so it goes longer or deeper into the
into the system before you take it up so
it you don't have the same stress on the
stomach right but it's saying that also
before one of the big sessions I had
before Kona I felt fine and we went
running it was a brick session and we
came maybe
yeah 10K into one and I just vomited
everything I had in my stomach and I
don't know if it was the Morton or the
heat or what it was but at that point I
was
a bit stressed for the race right
because uh yeah under two weeks out and
vomiting is not optimal when you're
better racing so
um
still with the best product in the world
you can do things wrong and uh I was
lucky I didn't but it didn't happen to
rain didn't you just have a Coke yeah
but I really felt like I felt it coming
okay and I tried to just have some
different taste in my mouth and just
drink something different so I felt like
okay now I'm gonna puke yeah took like
the smallest sip of coke and they're
just everything came up that's scary
also I'm sure being a student of the
sport and knowing that many a great
Champion has been felt by that very
thing like macca talks about it all the
time it took him years to figure out
like how to not have gi distress just so
he could like run the way that he had
trained to run to win the race yeah but
we are
we're kind of Lucky in both of us
because we can handle
a great amount in training but also in a
day-to-day life just eating a lot so but
figuring that out there was a very
scientific approach that I I can't wait
to talk to Olaf about I mean I know that
you would drink water that was laced
with Isotopes to try to figure out your
you know what not just like how much
glycogen you should be taking in but you
know whether or not the glycogen you
were burning was from your glycogen
stores versus the foods that you were
eating like getting really data driven
about the specifics of that to kind of
dial in what that nutrition plan should
be
yeah that was more to find out what our
actual uh consumption of or figuring out
see the whole budget you can train
because if because with the the water
that we drank and then later on Pete on
every morning you could see then how
many calories we could burn through over
like
two weeks period of time without losing
weight and then we really tried to do as
much training as possible and based on
these numbers then it would have can
then in this training plan you can see
that okay if you do
this amount or this so long bike ride
with this power then you're going to
burn through so many calories and if we
do this every day then you will be
burned out because you can't eat enough
so it's more for him to have this
uh budget of how much he can actually
give us in training right so we have a
lot of people with us or more before but
we had a lot of people joining us for
training camps and we call it the 10-day
crack so a lot of people can train a lot
for a week without feeling uh burnt out
but after about 10 days then you when
you're training too much every day and
you're eating too little and just like
fading slowly every day you won't notice
until it's been overdue and at 10 days
most people will crack and either get
injured or sick or just tired in bed
so it's uh it's definitely a real thing
to see how much you're eating and try to
compensate
one of the things I noticed washing you
guys race the other day was just how
frequently you would look at your watch
right and I was like what are I want to
know what the data fields are on on your
whatever I don't know if it's a garment
or whatever watch you were wearing like
are you just looking at heart rate Pace
you know on the bike watts is this also
a reflection of of your continuous
glucose monitor like what were the data
points that you were most interested in
staying on top of for the run for me
it's it's a comfort thing I think so I
feel like I was running slower and
slower so they just have the number of
the pace that I was actually running
my prescribed paste that was uh so it
it's not OCD but it's a comfort thing to
to get confirmation okay you're on track
you're on track you're on track and what
else you're supposed to do out there
it's uh if you entertain yourself with
looking at the distance it's just
increasing towards the marathon yeah so
I looked also at the time just counting
down okay now it's about 20 more minutes
and I can do this so just Pace distance
yeah mostly for me and run it's
basically only Pace yeah and what about
you I have heart rate total time for the
Run
pace and distance so using those four
and just
yeah entertaining myself and making sure
that the heart rate doesn't Spike right
like if you suddenly have a crazy Spike
and it's super hot out you can't come
back from that which kind of gets into
Core Body temp uh stuff which obviously
is hugely important once you kind of tip
over a certain Core Body temp uh you're
in big trouble right so talk a little
bit about the work that you guys have
put into maintaining a lower Core Body
temp throughout the day in hot locations
yeah so it's not uh trying to maintain a
slow Core Body temp as possible just
trying to it's not like it's more to
tolerate the the body temperature
but I was looking at the at my watch and
on the bike and I was surprised actually
how low it was I guess it was lower
temperature that day as well but in
training I've been pushing way above 39
degrees at the warmest days and uh so so
how are you measuring Core Body temp
like you have you you have something
inside you that's syncing up with your
watches there's a secret proprietary no
before we had to uh to put the pill
inside and the normal way to do it was
to to swallow it but the issue there is
you don't know exactly where the the
temperature pill is and also if you
drink cold water you would affect the
measurements so to be more precise we
had to put it in the other end and that
became repository yeah it became a bit
of a hassle after some time because we
have to use yeah single-use pills
obviously and
um just download the data no live feed
or anything so uh we got in contact with
a Swiss company that's called core and
it's a device you put on the heart rate
monitor instead ah and we have been
helping them develop their algorithms
and yeah so that's interesting so you
are getting a live feedback yeah on your
watch yeah you know what your Core Body
temp is and you also know the specific
point at which
if you tip over it you're going to be in
trouble right but with that knowledge
how does that translate into the like
gauging your effort is live is saying
with the heart rate like uh if it's
constantly increasing then you know that
you are in the bath or bad bad uh
pattern by the way so uh you just want
to keep it like steady and if you're
increasing the pace it's okay if it's
the core temperature is increasing too
but if you're certainly riding at the
same power and you just gradually going
higher and higher than you know that you
will soon hit the wall so it's more
you're looking at the numbers combined
together not just one single number and
what's really interesting that I learned
from uh using the course that you don't
feel warm when you're warm you feel warm
when the temperature is increasing so
you can go from 37 to 38 and feel really
warm at 38 because the temperature is
rising so rapidly but you can go also
from 39.5 down to 39.3 and and feel
freezing because the temperature is
going down so with that knowledge on the
on the run you can look at the watch and
see okay are you actually warm now or
you just slight increase in temperature
feeling warm so you can be more
yeah have more data points than trusting
the feeling because temperature is a
really strange thing you can like this
water is almost room temperature but it
feels cold because the energy transfer
is higher but the air doesn't feel cold
at all right so it's uh temperature is
really really hard to get like a feeling
of from the human body that's super
interesting yeah not intuitive then yeah
at all so to have the the core monitor
on just like at the side of the body
instead of using the pills every day
it's a
it's a good thing for us right
um at some point in the race like all of
this stuff is is instructive and
informative when you're out on the race
course and you're you know four hours
into an eight-hour day or whatever it is
um but at some point you know the rubber
meets the road and you're racing right
you have to adapt you got to react to
you know what's happening out on the
course and and kind of just say [ __ ] it
right like when you're in the whole
Christian and you're like all right
Gustav's making a move like all that
[ __ ] goes out the window right because
you gotta you gotta bust it so how do
you make those decisions or
um you know kind of balance all of the
data with like I'm an athlete in the
middle of a race trying to win
I I think you need to so you have your
numbers like in your data bank then when
you're on on the race course you have
your kind of the your upper limit
numbers that you know that you can do
but just for a short period of time so
for example on the bike it's not your
like you're just going out at your
steady arm and power like when someone
is urging and you try to follow and and
you're looking around and seeing how
they feel is responding and then hoping
that the pace will slow down later on
and uh so
sometimes the bike can be like 30 Watts
higher but then you hope that it's the
same consequences for everyone and
everyone that will have to do the none
runs lower right yeah so you'll
constantly have to evaluate and I think
having the data points and our training
really gives us more information
so uh uh but with more information you
also have to do even more choices
because uh yeah you know the
consequences of every thing so I could
write 400 watts for yeah shorter period
of time but uh you know it's on the
other side of that yeah I know it's on
the other side and then right like he
got he got this bank right and you can
you know you can make certain
withdrawals that if you make too many
with you know that extra withdrawal if I
do that this is going to happen so you
just have to take calculated risks and
know the the consequences of those
decisions yeah and you just have to hope
you have a bigger bank right even like
up to hobby halfway through on the bike
course we had a huge search yeah like uh
yeah 370 Watts for like 10 minutes wow
in the middle of the race just to bridge
up to the guys three guys in front it
was just before same Layla was breaking
away and I had good stuff like on my
wheel or I had to catch up to you before
that as well I had like 30 minutes there
with way above Race and then I thought
okay this is hurting so badly it's above
threshold
uh and uh
I just hope that this will hurt good
stuff more than me if I can make it up
to the guys upfront without him then I
can get an easier travel back to Kona
right and then maybe have four minutes
on him so much for working together yeah
you were trying to put distance on him
all the way back then yeah and I I saw
this and I was like this is the move oh
like this is uh yeah so yeah none of the
commentators said anything about that
well I think it's hard to see from the
outside but I just saw Christian in
front and I knew that if he caught up
with the front group and I didn't catch
up with him that I would have a really
really hard time getting back because I
was alone at that time uh we had just
um broken away from our group and uh
yeah I just saw that this was the yeah
if I don't make this the race is over
it's done yeah so it really had to go
way above Race Pace to to make it but
you know you got that downhill after the
turnaround yeah but the downhill is
still hard yeah and it's even though
you're not drafting downhill when you
have that many athletes and a motorcycle
it's a huge boost being behind but it's
still you still have to work for it
Russia there was a lot of speculation
about what was going on inside your your
jersey on the bike like what did you
have stuffed in there like everyone's
like what is that is he trying to cool
his Core Body temp did you just have
bottles in there it was a bit random
actually so uh we tried it in a winter
earlier this year and it's basically no
Aero penalty it's slightly faster in
crosswind but it's not not really any
difference but the thing is uh I had a
bottle in transition one and usually we
have this books in transition with our
bikes where you can throw away your
things and I
yeah I just didn't think it through so
when I came to the bike I went to like
throw away the bottle but was nothing
there because Iron Man translations this
they're different than a normal ones and
I knew if I just throw away the bottle
down I would get a penalty so first I
had it in my pocket anywhere but it
almost fell out so now I thought hmm
maybe I should just put it in my jersey
and make like a story out of it and
people will repeat it in the future for
like Aero Games but it's uh yeah it was
not real about the gains it was not
getting interesting yeah it was like is
this shape in here making it more
aerodynamic he's trying to look more
like me yeah yeah
um well the aerodynamic stuff is super
interesting too I mean most people are
familiar with cyclists going into the
wind tunnel or time trial is trying to
really dial in that aerodynamic position
but once again you guys have gone next
level you did all this testing on a
track with what's it called like body
rocket yeah so what was going on there
that you know elevated your
understanding of of being optimally
aerodynamic So currently oh so we've
spent a lot of days in winter this
winter just to be able to dial in the
position on the bike but the problem
there is that the feeling you have in
the winter Channel isn't necessarily the
way of writing outside and especially me
when I'm riding I'm changing position
quite a lot and I've been moving the
saddle a couple of centimeters back and
forth like during the ride no no like
yeah or just experimenting experimenting
over like a training camp a Christian is
insane it's like yeah he can go one
session and then no I don't have any
power let's go up with a saddle four
centimeters no it's not even millimeters
it's like okay I'm gonna rise my and
raise my saddle so much right now or I
think I need to go down and I go down
and no I have to go up
uh it's been tricky to find the body
position no um yeah position on the bike
um the body rocket is like trying to
bring what you do in the Wind Tunnel out
in the field so it has like sensors
underneath your air bars like a small
sensor there and also underneath your
saddle and in your pedals so by this way
you are separating your body from the
bike so without riding you can measure
all the wind that's coming to your body
and you can measure where on the bike
that you are getting the forces so if
you can see that you're not really
aerodynamic in your front of your like
with your arms or if it's your lower
back or where the
CDA numbers is increasing that's some
formula one [ __ ] that's like next level
but the vectors that you gotta
factor in are not just aerodynamics but
Comfort you're gonna be on the bike for
four plus hours and power right power
transfer so any you know it's like yeah
you can get super aerodynamic but if
that's not translating into Watts or if
you're so uncomfortable that you're
gonna cramp or you're just not going to
be able to sustain it that's not going
to work either yes you need to have a
good balance between the hamstring use
and the quad use as well because of you
you do have to go out and run the
marathon after it so it's not just
uh about getting as fast as possible on
the bike right and your your positions
are very different what's interesting
Christian like also your bikes are
different you have a very unique bike
Christian I don't know what's going on
with that bike and and kind of a weird
odd position like you're much more
upright and your arms are you know like
up high as well so how did that how did
you arrive upon I feel I feel I haven't
arrived yet to necessarily where I want
to be it's been like a long a process of
uh getting there but uh yeah it's just
the fact that I want to keep my power
high and not just because if I go too
low and I feel my stomach and chest goes
into the knees and then I'm losing power
so it's more being able to still think
about the run after the bike
while Gustav is made more flexible and
yeah and uh I feel like I'm a natural
cyclist and my cycle or my bike position
is quite similar to that of uh like time
trial specialist in in the Tour de
France so I have more like a traditional
bike position yeah yeah yeah and that's
just through rigorous testing you've
figured this yeah and also yeah and what
feel natural we've been to the uh or
been to the winter myself as well and we
did just minor changes was basically no
changes because uh for me I knew that my
position was quite fast based on power
numbers and uh yeah analysis we've done
before so we just had like slight
increase in angle of the arms and um
yeah right small optimization right
um
how are you guys feeling about the fact
that uh fredino didn't race is he uh on
your mind is the mono imano against Yan
looming in the future and how are you
thinking about that rivalry of course I
have both
the Hawaii right still to win and I've
never raced against the honor so uh we
will see what's happening in the future
you only have one very politically
correct answer I think come on man
you're not afraid to trash talk a little
bit you only have one more year I think
so yeah he's an old man see what's
happening next year but it's free it's
three weeks between the Grand Final and
Hawaii next year so
it's going to be a quick turnaround
cool stuff uh I don't feel like I'm
driving driven the same way with rivalry
as Christian I'm I
yeah I want to win but and I want to
beat the best but I don't have like this
particular guys that I want to beat I
just want to beat everyone so I don't
have the need to beat young to feel
better about myself but I feel it would
be cool to race against him like he's
yeah for sure yeah the best in the sport
since 2008 and yeah I've been over a
decade on top of the sport and really
changed long distance Triathlon so
just to take that opportunity to raise
him I think is something yeah I had
opportunity in California last year but
then we had this insane storm coming in
for Iron Man and the race got canceled
in race morning so yeah we went on the
same start line but never got the race
right uh so Jan was the first to become
an Olympic gold medalist and then when
at Kona but it took him seven years to
do it and two konas I think I have that
correct uh you guys you Christian you
won the Olympic gold and then won St
George which is technically the world
championship but with this asterisk
because it wasn't Kona and Kona has this
mystique and all of that
um so yes there's still a little
unfinished business there for you and he
is the goat
um but he's you know he's getting he's
getting up there in years
um I would love to see that race and I
hope that it I hope that it transpires
we'd all like to see that I think but it
leaves me wondering about
um
you know other Heroes that you might
have like do you look at other sports
and who are the people that you look to
for inspiration or maybe you don't maybe
you're just like I'm good man I'm the
champ I don't think
uh it's not that we don't have too many
Idols in other sport but I think we just
uh find inspiration in the work we do
and the conversation we have in the team
I know yeah me and Christian we don't
have any
you have posters on your wall of this
guy or that guy so it's uh yeah I don't
know why but I don't have like any huge
sporting Heroes well when I started like
uh seeing like short distance Triathlon
on TV like 10 years ago that was the era
of Javier Gomez and Alistair and Johnny
and how they were changing the sport so
I guess I was back then looking after
like how they were dominating the race
and really racing effectively uh
attacking from the start and just like
being in the front seat and I think that
has maybe been more my inspiration in
Triathlon more than long distance really
because
who have always had like the dream
towards the Olympics rather than Ironman
actually so it's more like the short
distance athletes that has been my
inspiration
no no like no like heroes in football
the Bergen team's terrible though right
yeah we we don't talk about we don't
talk about them I was reading I grew up
as a cyclist so yeah obviously a tourist
out
uh was a huge inspiration right done but
a sprinter yeah
um I was reading Brad culp's article the
Red Bull article that he went and
visited uh you Christian in in Bergen
and was talking about this confidence
that people from Bergen have that is
different from the typical kind of
Norwegian humility and I feel like you
guys both have that like you're humble
and you're grounded but you also have
this quiet confidence about you we have
this saying that we're not from Norway
we're from Bergen so I think it's like
that's
self-belief and the
inner self from Bergen yeah
um
can we talk about the sub-7 thing for a
couple minutes yes you wanna I'm gonna
head out
just for a minute I don't want to spend
too much time on it but it's super
fascinating for people that don't know
much like that uh sub
two project where kipchoge tried to
break two hours in the marathon
similarly there was a an uh a project
whereby you would be able through Aid to
try to Eclipse The Seven Hour barrier in
the Iron Man you did that would you go
like 644 or something like that yeah six
something like that yeah you were
getting pulled by you know a Peloton of
cyclists and paced on the run and all
kinds of stuff
um
feels like a stunt I know that wasn't
this was not like a focus of your
program by any stretch of the
imagination but I feel like it's
something that gets people who aren't
necessarily fans of triathlon excited
about Triathlon because it's something
we can all kind of wrap our heads around
so I'm wondering are you gonna take
another stab at that because I think
there's a lot I think I think 6 30 is
well within range with the right team
and support yeah it was a really fun
project to be able to be a part of like
we had 10 guys we could use however we
wanted like a crosswind back and run we
ended up with one on the swim eight on
the bike and one on the run and uh it
ended up being more actually a race
between my team and Joe Skipper's team
and just making the cut under seven
hours right so uh it was a really cool
project both to my like for training for
myself to get physically fit enough to
do it but I also like the whole build up
with the team and organizing with the
Pacers and
the whole
it was like a team feeling of going into
it right so many people come into play
to really pull that off it's like it's
like a it's like a ballet almost of and
you know coming in and out both
had like a lot of tough weeks of getting
it organized and getting the team
trained together and dialed in and uh
it's nice to look back and see that we
actually
did beat the other guys and also got sub
seven so
uh great uh experience but any plans to
do it again
uh not in the first few years yeah like
the schedule now for a while for going
into Paris is so busy like
to turn around now to go back to short
distances maybe more or higher
priorities than trying to do something
similar
uh having spent all this time at all
these races you just got back from Kona
you're you know one of the unique things
about Triathlon is that you race with
the amateurs like you go to these huge
races but there's you know most of the
people there are Average Joe's and
Jane's what are the Colossal fails and
and tragic mistakes that you see
amateurs making like where you're just
like you're out training you know a
couple days before the race and you see
people out there and you go back to your
condo and you're like keep leading that
guy what is it what are these people
doing I think what's unique about
Triathlon is that everyone have so much
knowledge about training and they are
really yeah they have a lot of knowledge
but it just comes down to execution and
uh just quality of training I think so
uh they might know like all the values
for their altitude and those things but
yeah still I don't train
as much I guess and uh not training
enough
yeah I don't know it depends like if you
have a normal job I mean most people
can't yeah so that's sort of out of
their hands but I'm thinking of like
simple things that you see people doing
where they're like that guy's got it all
wrong like seriously dude yeah yeah like
out there a lot of people they're doing
intervals like two days before the race
a lot of people just uh they have a
really good plan on the bike for a
training session before and then they
see me and Christian writing past and
their plan they go start a window and
they just have to follow follow book up
put out their phone ride past us and
take a selfie and then let down I don't
think that's the smartest move but uh I
think most translates are training yeah
training good and it's hard to pinpoint
exactly what they're doing wrong because
I think most people are doing quite the
right things for me you've definitely
have media training but honestly
athletes are they are in the Forefront
yeah sure yeah I mean it's triathlon's
always been at The Cutting Edge of like
science because they're tinkerers and
they're willing to you know try new
things that perhaps professional
cyclists or professional runners you
know won't and I think that's cool and
unique about the sport
um
but you know I am interested in uh
perhaps you guys uh conveying a little
bit of wisdom about what you've learned
over the many years that would be
applicable to the average endurance
athlete or endurance Enthusiast perhaps
somebody who's out there contemplating
their first marathon or their first
Olympic triathlon like where should
their focus be placed and what types of
things should they I not worry about
that maybe they spend too much time
thinking one of the things sometimes is
fun is to see how you can have amateurs
being more professional in terms of
recovery and what we are I could do all
the messes you do the
recovery Booth ice bath but I think the
most important thing of our factor is
iteration and enough sleep
so if they can just kind of throw out
those hours that you think on their
typical recovery thing and just getting
more calories in and sleeping enough I
think that's really going to be
beneficial yeah but then you don't get
to buy the cool stuff and you know a lot
of it is about the the blingy stuff in
the triathlon too I think
then they can invest it in equipment
instead you know right that's one uh
yeah level higher bike price so for the
recovery piece what does that look like
for you guys I mean sleep obviously do
you do uh ice baths sauna Norma Tech
boots like all that kind of stuff we do
nothing yeah you don't do any of that
the nutritional sleep and temporary
controlled yeah yeah I was watching
um uh Lionel Sanders Vlogs you know
I guess you know he's he was staying at
Chris liato's house he's got an ice bath
and they were like playing around the
ice bath and wine I was like I can't do
it I don't want any part of this but we
don't do that either like yeah
especially preparing for a warm race
like uh cool enough we wouldn't do ice
bath like that
yeah well it's interesting and maybe
this is a question for Olaf but so many
of those recovery modalities I often
wonder
um
are they robbing the athlete of the
adaptation to exercise induced stress
that you're looking for like you want
your body to have a response to the
strain that you just put it through and
if you do too much recovery stuff are
you undermining like what you're
actually trying to achieve yeah the
antioxidants in altitude right so people
take antioxidants because they don't
want to get the body inflamed and uh
yeah health benefits and it's good up to
a certain amount but if you do too much
you actually yeah as you just mentioned
you you don't get all the benefits
because you need some kind of
information or else you want to build
back stronger but I don't think uh doing
50 minutes of massage is
do having any effect if it's a comfort
thing it's a comfort thing you can do it
but for me I would never spend time to
go out of bed to meet someone and have a
massage for me it's better to just relax
and watch YouTube or listen to podcast
or something so just relax when I can
and do
do that well yeah interesting same for
you yes we have the same program there
yeah yeah what do you guys uh what do
you what do you do in your limited free
time I know I know a Christian likes to
watch Dexter yeah he likes watch you
watch Dexter right the psycho killer
he's your hero there's a poster of him
on your wall yeah like uh up in the
ceiling yeah it's all about Obsession
normally we squeeze in like a power nap
with like we'll just like in bed and
just recovering until the next session
so we so I think if it's your daily work
and now we do like how we spend our days
it can be very
boring for a lot of people and it's very
simple like you swim back and running
and just with the meals in between and
probably not midday yeah so a typical
day for us in altitude is waking up at
uh 7 30 go to the pool at like 8 15 swim
for 90 minutes go back eat lunch have a
power nap and a power nap for us it's
not the five minute standard it's not
the 10 minutes it's like more an hour
midday just sleeping and then eat some
more have a bike ride two two and a half
hours three hours and then a short run
make dinner so an attitude or in front
of you make the dinner yourself every
day
and then we eat then we have a
conversation with ulav about the
training the next day and now we go to
bed so in that schedule we don't have
too much time
more than Dexter so maybe you can ask
him afterwards if he can start like
doing
two by 30 minutes of massage so where
where would you fill that then well the
the swan year comes to you yeah yeah
yeah you don't have to go anywhere no
but as a cyclist yeah I would think
you'd be all in on that yeah but
cyclists only have uh one session a day
you know so it's easy to fit in an
afternoon Slackers yeah
like they train maybe the same amount of
hours but they have one session five
hours concentrated it's easier to use
the the free time but we have yeah
swimming takes a lot of time it's always
transportation and you have to change
and yeah swimming just takes a lot of
time but while cycling and running you
can always start from your house
basically so um yeah and also we have to
figure out what we're going to train the
next days a lot of logistics and for us
we can say when we finish swimming okay
we're gonna ride at two
and then we come closer to two and say
no it's better to push it to one or two
three so to have an extra person like uh
I must use into this whole picture to
plan around it's just adding to the
stress too complicated yeah so we like
to have a flexible schedule and that's
why we don't plan too much training with
other people either yeah so we just say
okay we run in 10 minutes so uh and are
you guys roommates throughout all of
this no we are but Christian is a heavy
breather during the night and I'm my
ears I actually swore now I have like a
blood day here because you share the
same bedroom now we do yeah just for
just for four days here no and we did in
two and a half weeks and uh yeah we're
in Hawaii that's true yeah yeah no
girlfriends so I have no girlfriends no
no no no no no but I have to wear my
earpods in the air to just cancel out
all the noise but it's it's getting a
bit those lungs man yeah too much uh
oxygen
around your own bedrooms yeah we usually
at this point yeah being super famous
celebrities usually we have but now it
was a bit uh with Logistics and the Kona
on here so it's sometimes they have to
share but
it's okay for a shorter period but now I
feel like it's been a bit too long so
it's going to be good to have my own
bedroom uh final thing and then I'll let
you guys go and uh I'm just curious
about mindset like how you maintain your
focus on on these goals and and stay
plugged in when the going gets tough and
you know I don't know it's the middle of
the winter and you're just it's session
session session like you are living a
very monk-like existence in order to
achieve these you know insane goals that
you've set for yourself how do you you
know stay fresh with that and
um
and you know goal oriented
yeah it's uh it's strange because I had
the same goal for so many years to take
the
to Tokyo Olympic gold and uh done after
the race I just felt like was this it
well I have everything I've been working
towards
did I do enough and everything
and after that I was a bit kind of
empty for some time because I didn't
have a bad performance I came top 10 in
my first Olympics and I was
like happy with my performance in itself
but I didn't reach my goal my long-term
goal for yeah 10 years
and uh after a week I just already on to
the next one and was Paris and uh ready
to to go again and I don't do anything
particular with my my motivation or
anything for me it comes quite natural
so
um yeah I don't know no like like sort
of practices or mantras or techniques
that you not really and I don't watch
any like try out some videos to get
myself motivated or like motivational
speeches or anything for me it's
it comes from within and it's a natural
thing
I guess Dexter's your North your North
Star it's just in the DNA watching you
like I'm very motivated by a racist so
even though I had the very opposite
experience with Tokyo winning the goal
or race that I was working towards for
10 years basically straight after I was
thinking about Hawaii like I really
wanted to win Hawaii and back then I
first had to qualify before I go to wild
card and uh
um yeah it's just yeah setting new
targets and if it goes wrong like
you know in Hawaii when I finished the
Third
then and they're watching the pictures
uh when he's crossing the Finish Line
first and I just think that okay in 12
month time and I
do when they cross the finished on
Thursday again so it's more the fire is
burning hot when it's going well you
just want to repeat it again when it's
going not that well then it's even more
like a slap in the face and I can wake
up and try to get back on track yeah but
it's easier to be motivated when you see
Christian also motivated and I get to
the same for Christian for me so we do
feed off each other in that way right
and we don't spread like the or
sometimes we do sometimes like life is
hard yeah there must be most you're like
I'm sick of this guy like I need I need
to hang out with someone else yeah the
Christian is really Direct in that way
he just puts on his uh airpods and in
Thailand I mean you can go training
sessions even though we train together
like we're not talking at all and then
we can have some training session we
like talking for three hours straight
right so uh even though we are like
together we gave him each other like the
space it's not often I put in the
airports though no but yeah the signal
leave me alone it can be a week straight
but it's not often
it's not it doesn't necessarily need to
be reason for it's just like the mood
yeah wow and when you when you when you
do put the airpods in and the training
are you listening to music or what do
you what do you listen to it can be
everything sometimes just noise
canceling on how real oh wow interesting
yeah but it's uh it's easier to uh to
train with someone when you know like
we're in this together we have the same
Ambitions we have to
yeah and uh also now going into uh to
Kona we looked at each other as far
as the biggest competitors so we had a
training session we had a lunch at the
Four Seasons and the food was a bit too
good so we ate a bit too much and now we
came to the run in the afternoon and uh
yeah we both had a a bad day but since
they both like our biggest competitors
when I said okay I'm gonna stop it now
we're gonna I'm gonna create the session
Christian said okay then I can stop as
well but that was more as a joke though
yeah but still yeah yeah
but yeah that was uh so so you went to
toilet after first in the wall and I
went out to the Bronx and had to pick up
the lunch so so that that's what
happened when I'm not in charge of the
planning of the day putting on a run
session straight after lunch
yeah so you you left a deposit of uh of
of your own body on the lava Fields
there for LA to kind of bite that's good
karma must be good karma yeah
um well
I have so much admiration and respect uh
for both of you guys I'm a huge fan and
it was a delight watching you guys go
head to head the other day and I can't
wait to see what you guys accomplish in
the years to come so uh at your service
and it was Delight to talk to you so
thank you thank you thank you very much
yeah I love this Bromance it's good I
hope you guys stay together forever at
some point you're gonna need girlfriends
but we're working on it yeah working so
hard on it but the problem here again
with his consequences so he could pull
stuff like this um the voice of God yeah
it proves of this Statistics that the
athletes with girlfriends they perform
worse than the ones without so always
with the consequences it's up to you
yeah I know but I have the choice but
you have to know that if you go through
with this then you last month you're
done yeah yeah so uh yeah playing on
consequences all right well yeah you
could put that that data point in maybe
after Paris yeah we'll see okay yeah uh
well come back and talk to me again you
guys super fun cheers thank you thank
you thank you peace
[Music]